yeah you knew I'd make some spoiler
chitchat video for a Hunger Games
Catching Fire it had to happen because
there are a lot of things on my mind
about the movie remember in my review I
told you there are a few parts what do
you think about it you're like could
that work we're talking about a few of
those here that's a big spoiler warning
for those of you out there who have not
seen Catching Fire if you haven't seen
it you can watch this video but don't
hate me when things are spoiled for you
that being said let's talk about the
movie what I really like when the movie
started out is you really see the post
traumatic stress disorder that Katniss
is going through the first Hunger Games
it establishes she's a really good
hunter and I myself personally put that
under the flag of what that means could
kill her Elsa so when she wasn't just
going through and tearing people up I
was like why why the hide-and-seek games
in the trees but it's almost like hey
Jeremy douchebag she's a human being
she's not a killer she's killed a few
people and now she just sees it all the
time she wakes up in cold sweats and I
was like yeah i Sigourney Weaver from
aliens thing going on I [ __ ] it must
have been stressful for it I really like
that it just gives layers to the
character you know it's not just cut and
dry like boom boo-boom I won I read this
bathing riches or at least if not riches
middle-class to today's standards but
that's like living like a king in this
world everything sucks in the world of
The Hunger Games President Snow's a
douchebag I'm just telling you right now
he's this movie illustrates how much of
a dick he actually is it's not like he's
some businessman just like my empire is
crumbling she must be dealt with no he's
like I look like Santa and no gifts are
coming this year I'm an [ __ ] my
douchebaggery is just it's without limit
Sicari that's what he has he has severe
dickery
I love the scene when Katniss sits down
with Cedric dickery over here because I
like it when the hero sits down with the
villain and they talks on a civil talk
but I still like it when they're face to
face we're like okay no guns right now I
feel like shit's gonna get real soon now
however I had a few questions about the
movie jumping to the end of the movie a
few people were in on a huge plot a huge
scheme to plant Katniss into The Hunger
Games and they were all in on it and a
lot of the tributes were also smarmy was
in honor he is smarmy that's what his
name is smarmy he's a real star of the
show though let's be honest it's not
Katniss and the crew it's smarmy and his
marmalade so this is act 1 in the plot
was smarmy in the marmalade but there
are a few things that are unanswered
like hey Mitch had this whole plot with
the plot I think revolved around him
being outside of the Hunger Games
otherwise he couldn't have gotten the
ship and
got her out of there so how much was
betta in on it what's he in on the whole
thing was it all part of the plan for
him to volunteer as tribute and Haymitch
his plays or is it possible that he
wasn't and that was not part of the plan
that was him just being like I I'm gonna
do this because I like hey Mitch in
which case what if when Lady gaga read
off hey Mitch's name Peeta was just like
good luck man the I ain't saying [ __ ]
I'm not an idiot and Hema should be like
[ __ ] I well I guess I'm in there now
we'll take on the evil empire next year
and in the end you find out the game
maker Philip Seymour Hoffman is actually
a good guy cool what about all those
times where Katniss really could have
died because of the [ __ ] he threw at her
in the game like when he's like spin the
Cornucopia and fling them all off there
that seemed pretty dangerous I think her
life was actually in peril at that point
you see her getting flung off into the
water and he's like alright stop it you
think he was like alright stop oh [ __ ]
she could she could die she could be
dead yeah that could have killed her I
think smarmy had it under control
killing all the dicks that were trying
to kill them maybe he had to assess
alright what's more dangerous a few
[ __ ] on the Cornucopia trying to
kill Katniss or spinning it and having
her possibly drowned
I picked drown drown her or not drown
her make it look like she's gonna drown
but we're not gonna drown her you don't
know that though I do the acid cloud is
arguably the most dangerous part of the
entire movies big acid cloud is coming
after them and you're like this is gonna
gobble them up and they're all gonna die
horrible deaths you see that they
control the acid cloud because it all
just up like there's an invisible wall
there and it goes away when it has to
you're like ah luck of the draw not luck
though Philip Seymour Hoffman obviously
had it under control but I'm saying what
if when it was nipping Katniss's heals
what if she tripped and sprained her
ankle and it's just like Groot dead oh
there goes to hope for revolution or
[ __ ] maybe she gets martyred and then
there's a revolution anyway either way
they win but there are so many variables
I have to think about what's the
possibility that Katniss could have died
in this whole situation your plan goes
to [ __ ] to be clear I'm not bitching
about Catching Fire just have a few
questions look at the end of the movie
at the end of the movie she shoots an
arrow up at this little spot in the dome
and the lightning hits it and it blows
the dome apart which is very cool then
the ship comes down catches her and has
Haymitch and Phillip Seymour Hoffman and
smarmy and all is right with the world
but the point is what if she didn't do
that did they all just get in the ship
and they float over there and they're
like okay I'm really wrong
she's going to shoot her arrow at this
thing right when the lightning hits odds
are kind of one-in-a-million that she's
going to but if she does were really
gonna make out good on this my question
is how did she know to do that in the
movie no one really told her to do that
that one dude who's a really good
scientist was like oh force fields a
glimmer when there's a weak spot
nothing's perfect so that alludes to the
fact that there is a spot but right
there was just kind of implication there
is no guarantee to Haymitch and Philip
Seymour Hoffman that she's going to
shoot the bow and arrow right when the
Lightning hits and blow the dome apart
so what if she didn't do that would they
just be hovering above the dome like all
right she didn't do it or we need to go
or else we're gonna die it didn't work
in the movie they wanted this big shock
like oh they were in on it like The
Crying Game ending or something you had
no idea and they hit you in the face
you're so surprised but because of that
no one could tell her to shoot that spot
in the dome and because of that you had
to see Philip Seymour Hoffman first hand
try to kill Katniss although he wasn't
trying to kill Katniss but really if you
look at it she really could have died a
few times so what if she did Philip
Seymour Hoffman to be like I think I'm
getting promoted at work
yeah Hamish is gonna hate me though I
guess this video for nothing else really
does show you that when I have questions
about a movie doesn't really hinder the
entire movie it is a cool movie about
revolution and I like that stuff that
really gets me so I enjoyed the [ __ ] out
of it doesn't change the fact it does
look like there are a few conveniences
in the movie but smarmy and most of his
marmalades made it out of there and
that's what matters I do love the fact
that there was a big scheming going on
it everyone was plotted cuz it's perfect
time to do it too because you got to
think at first I was like why did Philip
Seymour Hoffman give President Snow the
idea to bring back all the tribute but
when you think about it you see Katniss
has post-traumatic stress Haymitch is
like there are no winners in The Hunger
Games there are just survivors no one
wins and I'm sure a lot of the surviving
tributes feel that way so bringing all
those people together these people
who've experienced firsthand how
terrible the games are how bad this evil
empire is how much of a dick Santa Ducie
actually is so they're all of like mine
but like you know what yeah let's work
together bring this whole thing down
this is [ __ ] not all of them were in
on it only half of them were about half
of them were like yeah let's work
together here so that made sense why
Philip Seymour Hoffman was like let's
bring back all the surviving tributes
and it seems like a good idea you're so
screwed president dick how about the
scene where Lenny Kravitz got his ass
beat and probably killed
[ __ ] was nuts I really liked that steam
because it shows a psychological warfare
and I was like yeah kick his ass right
in front of her right she's going up to
fight the Hunger Games does beg the
question why did he stick around he
makes this suit that makes her a
Mockingjay pretty much tells president
douche huh and he sticks around to see
her off to the Hunger Games he had to
have known who's gonna get his ass
kicked and snuffed in the middle of
nowhere he should have been like I had
to put a surprise in her suit push this
button when you're ready I'm gonna be
somewhere else in the entire world cuz I
just don't want to die today yeah when
you manufacture a Mockingjay suit for
the face of hope that exists to tell the
president of the evil empire to suck his
own dick
you should leave you should get out of
Dodge I loved that scene when president
dick is just standing there the lights
go out dude he's like it's not possible
you see that he feels his mortality
right there he's like that little girl
is bringing my entire world down [ __ ] it
let's just waste her entire town and
they do at the end Gail's like they got
Peeta and they destroyed our towns like
sato from Karate Kid to made good on his
promise hello's the church ever though
gone and that's what happened Holmes
Church everything destroyed good and
then she just gets this pissed-off look
in her eyes and it ends and I was like
I'm really interested for the third one
oh the third and fourth one because
that's what the movies are gonna be
because this isn't the games anymore
it's the hunger revolution is what it is
what's smarmy and his marmalade and now
we're going to district 13 what is it
where is it how is it is it like
district 13 all the rumors we've ever
heard it's just a wasteland it's blown
up I don't know I just don't know what
district 13 is is it sand like three
people who are alive in a bunch of
rubble one person is that in the middle
no we're just doing a bunch of Steel
like welcome to district 13 I have no
idea I'm interested though I have a
feeling all of these questions I have
about the movie are answered in the
books somewhere or maybe they're
answered in the book because the book
did it differently but in terms of the
movie itself it does look like a lot of
conveniences happen it doesn't change
the fact that I really enjoyed catching
fire I had a blast with it I'm ready for
the third movie remember remember the
fifth of whatever date is going to be
but it's gonna be awesome
let's bring the [ __ ] down I love a good
rebellion Empire movie so Catching Fire
I'm sure a few of you out there have
read the book these questions I have
that the movie didn't really illustrate
answers to are they answered in the book
that the book do a different line
curation no because I
the comments section of a YouTube video
is a haven for people who want to be
liked actually it was done like this
this time I want to hear it I want these
answers so please comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here see more
[Music]